what do we do with people like you in
society people who are talented and
brilliant but also take risks and make
mistakes and sometimes say things that
are insensitive and some people find
always insensitive yeah
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people returning to the show today we
have one of britain's most brilliant
historians and a very controversial one
of that dr david starkey welcome back
hello uh i reference deeply i'm going to
absolutely put you on the spot i should
be so straight forward calm neutral
totally uncontroversial yeah i doubt
that very much david
back to you to tease it out of me um
we'll do our best but welcome back uh
last time we had you on the show as you
alluded to in our conversation prior to
starting we were in a very different
place but i put it to you that so were
you
how have you been this past 18 months
uh much as i am now
um
i take it you're referring to the
unfortunate and dramatic events of
last july or were you just talking about
kovitt no no i i was talking about the
fact that shortly after we had you on
the show you were speaking to darren
grimes on his show you made what i think
you said in one of your recent
interviews with stupid remarks for which
you apologized and there since then
ensued a whole milestone of various
things so tell us about that
yes well i
i did make a stupid remark i used the
word damn in front of the word blacks
which was a very stupid thing to do on
the other hand what i was saying which
is that slavery is not genocide or at
least the atlantic trade slavery is not
genocide is a straightforward statement
of fact
about 300 000 um black people were
exported or they were treated as
chattels
were exported enslaved ships to the
south of the what is now the united
states three hundred thousand
within
three generations
there are millions
now that's not a genocide but of course
what everybody forgets one
piece of slavery was a genocide and
that's the slavery to the islamic world
that is the slavery that actually goes
over land in africa to what was then
called the ottoman empire the best
estimates are it was 21 million
20 million
of whom the men were castrated
and the women were kept as concubines
and most of the children which were of
course mixed race
or whatever you want to call it ottoman
and african the children have their
brains dashed out that is a genocide
but we don't talk about that because
there's no white guilt there's no guilt
of david starkey in that so we don't
talk about it but of course david that
isn't the the the remark that people
took the issue with i think the remark
was down but there were so many yeah it
was it was
it was simply of course it was stupid it
what i was in and he also i even
mentioned right come on let's explore
i'm sure neither of you have ever said a
word
ever
ever said a word out of turn um i i
i committed a second stupidity i meant
to illustrate it by saying there
wouldn't be so many in america and my
tongue slipped and i said africa
deranged very very bad and for somebody
who prides himself on position of
language disgraceful on the other hand
one word damn
four
letters
if
people had had their wishes
an entire career would have been
destroyed for four letters who is
actually seriously hurt
why is a word one word
given this extraordinary weight isn't it
a bit religious
isn't it superstitious isn't it the kind
of verbal fetishism doesn't it smack of
national hysteria in other words exactly
for example what happened around the
death of diana or what the great another
great historian even greater than me uh
what lord mccauley described as the uh
nothing more ridiculous than the british
public in one of its fits of morality it
was a fit of morality well we should we
should come on we should you ask right
why am i why am i treating it relatively
lightly no no hold on hold on i'm not
saying uh i disagree with you you know
my view on this world stuff and all of
that and you know how much we like and
respect you on the show yeah uh you're
one of our favorite guests of all time
no question about that the the point i
would make to you is i don't think
people were concerned about the one word
what a lot of people said at the time
including people we respect also uh
people like catherine bobel singh who we
had on the show that this wasn't the
first time you'd had a slip of the
tongue in relation to race and so
so their perception was let me just
finish this their perception was that it
wasn't a individual instance of a
mistake which we all make all of us you
alluded to of course all of us make
slip-ups but rather that it was a
pattern of behavior that was reflective
of an attitude
towards race that was the point that
people made personally i didn't
necessarily agree with that but that was
the point that people made so what do
you say to them
i would love to see what they ever do
you see again i'm sorry i'm really
boring i believe in evidence uh i made a
comment at the time of the race riots in
2011 which said something seemed to me
to be absolutely true but was regarded
as being outrageous that these were
black riots which they were
the evidence is absolutely overwhelming
if you actually look at the maps of the
rats it was nothing to do directly with
impoverishment there were areas that
were very much more impoverished that
didn't riot
okay it was to do with a particular
attitude in other words a form of
imitation of urban behavior that has
been imported from america the riots you
know shopping with violence were very
very similar to the pattern that we saw
after floyd's death
um and it's a particularly important
pattern of behavior which is not i think
one that we were used to in britain
i think it's deeply unfortunate this is
nothing this is not so i am not
criticizing race
i am criticizing behavioral patterns i'm
not criticizing skin color i'm i'm
criticizing things that people decide to
do
right
in the same way why was i got agitated
on the question of whether it's genocide
or not why does that why why does that
question come up it comes up because i'm
afraid the whole question of slavery
monstrous though it is is deliberately
being weaponized in a specific cultural
context which is why
what i was talking about at the
beginning why what is the most monstrous
aspect of the slave trade is
deliberately ignored because it does not
attack the west the reason again that
there's a talk about slavery is genocide
you're a jew
unfortunately
there's a great problem with jews you
are
we're going to we're going to clip that
down
david starkey there is a big
a big problem
there is a big problem with jews which
is you are mope the most depressed
and that is a very jealously guarded
status and it's also one that people are
very jealous about black activists are
actually palestinian activists are
outraged at the fact that the genocide
gives you this kind of
moral is you know it's it is a testament
to a sick society that the genocide
becomes a kind of badge of pride weirdly
and bizarrely and this is why there is
attempt at portraying slavery in exactly
this fashion so that you can say the
whole of the west is guilty of
pseudo-nazism
haven't you observed how the left i
think we should start calling the far
left that is everybody even faintly to
the left of kierstama is far left um
look how far to the left he is have you
not noticed how they're all throwing
around the term nazi the term fascist
have you thought of the disgrace for
example of talking about the person that
i appeared with last night nigel farage
as a nazi or a fascist what is the
contempt that that shows for the victims
of the real nazis and the real fascists
that you again you relied the kind of
language that something like farage uses
with the concentration camps and the gas
chambers this is what i find deeply
deeply shocking scandalous and
disgraceful
that we are using these that we're
alighting these slips of tongue
with
monstrous behaviors and acts we've got
to separate words from action this is
this is the classic position in america
with with the first amendment and all
the rest of it that there is
absolute clear distinction between words
as words and words that invoke action
the famous remark the one thing you
can't say under freedom of speech is
fire in a theater because it provokes
behavior
but
it's a really good point david that
you've just made and we were talking
before how we've conflated words with
violence and words with action
but words have power and i would argue
to you that what those words are being
used nazi racist fascist anti-vaxxer now
what they're doing is they're using
words in order to shut down a discussion
of course in order to bludgeon somebody
into
not speaking their opinion as indeed a
previous authority that was very keen on
words and policing words the whole
business of the medieval church and the
use of heresy and heresy trials to shut
people up i mean it's fascinating again
putting the all these things together
you remember the great fuss that's being
made about the statue of cecil rhodes uh
on the front of oriole college at oxford
one of the other statues there that
nobody actually complains about is a man
called archbishop arundel who is an
early fellow of the college he is the
man who very nearly destroys the
university of oxford in about 1400 when
he uses the his power over the church of
england to issue uh the const arundel's
constitutions and they literally shut
down intellectual debate in england for
a century you know you you know
as a cambridge man i used to be quite
proud of being a cambridge man
but a long time ago well 18 months ago
last last period that we were talking
about before and
what arundel did to the university of
oxford um gave cambridge its chance um
uh does anybody notice this does anybody
care about it because the universities
public life in general our companies
have lost any notion of the value of
freedom of speech it seems to me to be
an absolute value if you want to look at
what distinguishes us what distinguishes
the west from the rest it is simply
freedom you know
as we're now discovering with china you
can actually have prosperity without
freedom
our only hope is that freedom which will
encourage the fermentation of ideas the
development of new technologies and so
on if i'm afraid you can have
new ideas without freedom were lost
were lost
i mean it's an excellent point the
problem is as well it's not just that
we're losing freedom of speech
we're also losing the ability to fight
for it people don't want to seem to
fight for the thing there's cowardice
cowardice again
at the moment i really do think we are
in a form of war
and some people can cope with war and
some people can't
some people can put their heads above
the parapet and some people can't
um
i
refused to bow the neck
i refused to take the knee i refused to
submit my mind to anybody i was very
fortunate i'm come from a long line of
dissenters i mean literal religious
religious descent i also had a mother
despite all the problems that we later
had over my sexuality who gave me an
iron self-confidence
and i've always taken a pride in that
again i
belong i was brought up in a strange
religious denomination the society of
friends quakers where there was this
in theory emphasis on plain speaking
plain on varnish speech
but why do you think we're at war
because that's a very bold statement and
also a lot of stupid people will you
know people don't understand metaphors
anymore they choose not to so what do
you mean when you say we're at war
i think it is the first time
right let's look at this um and try and
again pull back use karma language uh
non-metaphorical language when i grew up
uh the west was in a thing that was well
i was born at the end of a real war i
was born at the in 1945 at the very end
of the first world war my mother said
that i was the only person in kendall
who actually slept through v day
as contented baby then of course i grew
up with the cold war
and
which was also of course the great
nuclear standoff we knew there was a
power those of us who were at all
intelligent that wished destroyers that
had opposed values to the soviet union
the soviet union is seen off it
collapses under its own contradictions
the absurdities of communism you know
all of this stuff oh we've never tried
communism has any doctrine ever been
more rigorously pursued at a greater
cost of human life that dwarfs even the
horrors of nazism anyway communism
collapses and then at which point there
was this absurd man with the wondrous
name fukuyama came along and talked
about the inevitable triumph of the west
liberal capitalism and whatever but the
seeds of something different had been so
this was an internal enemy
a an attack on the absolute fundamentals
of western society we've really got to
understand this this is what
everybody jokes or we sort of joke about
woke because it is so preposterous and
it's so stupid i mean the idea that
merely by saying i want to be a woman i
am a woman you know this is again it's
religious uh france it literally is
religious i mean it is the equivalent of
the priest saying hawkes corpus i mean
the word transubstantiation of the word
transsexual it's the same word you're
trying to change one thing into another
merely by words it's incantatory it's
magic now this
this reversion to religious primitivism
this giving
language priority over fact
feeling priority over fact is it's a
deliberate reaction against modernity
against progress against science against
everything that has made our lives
better longer healthier more comfortable
than the lives of any human freer than
the lives of any human beings before and
so it is really an attempt at destroying
everything and it's purely destructive
at least communism thought it had an
alternative this has no alternative it i
mean it it
nobody is ever
these extraordinary people like like
professor whatever she called bhupal at
the college opposite
my former college at cambridge uh uh at
churchill college
that that she wants to see the
disappearance of whiteness now if that's
not an invocation to genocide i really
don't know what is i mean
destroy white values now so
people on bbc television mainstream
television the olympias of this world
want apparently to destroy whiteness now
what does that actually mean
it means if you're being polite they
want to destroy a culture well i think
that's called cultural genocide
but how would you destroy a culture
without destroying people unless you put
them in a concentration camp
see nobody bothers to interrogate this
language nobody puts them on the spot
all these big companies politely nod
their head the bbc nazis head the
metropolitan police nod it said even for
god's sake covent garden is nodding its
head
and so that's why
this is appeasement
this is the appeasement stage before war
i suppose i'm now identifying myself as
a new intellectual
modesty is the new intellectual
churchill i i would push back on the uh
saying that they don't want anything to
me these people are utopians just in a
way as a more misguided people in who
you
are
yeah but what you took right okay
francis i'll challenge you describe the
utopia they want okay they want a utopia
where we you know trans women are women
everybody lives free from the oppressive
patriarchal structures i'm not saying i
believe in it i'm just putting forth the
argument where racism isn't a problem
where white supremacy isn't a problem
where people are elevated
et cetera i think i think more more
succinctly it's they want the end of
which
yeah they want they want uh for everyone
to be equal and for there to be no
description now look we're more
intelligent than i understand those
things aren't always possible but that's
what they want no discrimination
everybody's equal well i've got no
problem with that but they want
discrimination they want discrimination
against whites they want preferential
treatment for people of different skin
pigmentation stormzy are sponsored
outrageously scholarships that came
between their own given to people with
black skins now that
sorry that is
that is what martin luther king fought
against with his life
isn't it
hey francis do you like books uh only
when they have pictures all the
waterproof ones i can take in the bath
with me all right well for those of you
who can read and enjoy reading satire in
particular we have just the book for you
what's that on shut up the book is
called woke fragility it's a brilliantly
funny takedown of robin d'angelo's white
fragility and woke culture more
generally it will keep you amused
through the small wee hours a
civilization collapses all around you
it's satire as it's meant to be allowing
you to laugh at things the powers that
be have now deemed off limits we all
know that comedy now is more toothless
than joe biden after he's removed his
dentures this is what you need to hit
the funny bone in these demented times
and it's received an average of 4.4
stars on amazon if you've already read
work for agility then tired moderate
also has two other books out the little
book of work jokes and scary stories to
tell the world in the dark a woke parody
of scary stories to tell in the dark
i'll read that book which one the little
one
find his books on amazon and enjoy a
satirical book that's funny and playful
moving on slightly uh one of the things
you pioneered in many ways you had tim
stanley the historian in here a few
weeks ago and he he was talking about
the one of the transformations and our
understanding of history that you were a
huge leader in was to re-emphasize the
role of the individual the huge
character the huge personality
and we are obviously operating right now
in extraordinary times by any historical
period i think it's fair to say with
with covert with lockdown with all of
the cultural stuff that's going on
who are the personalities of today who
are going to shape our historical
perspective on this period of time do
you think and what what is the process
that's happening now
very difficult to say i mean the
there's been a kind of
abdication hasn't there i mean there are
clearly big personalities under like
boris johnson
but you remember that that wonderful um
phrase of e cummings
that a a politician is a cushion upon
which everything is sat but a man
and the and and boris takes whatever
shape
i mean he's it's complete shape-shifting
it's it is a kind of
inflatable squidgy
funny cushion a kind of
perpetually shifting clown mask plastic
um
there are individuals
does anybody
i'm falling silent because
a handful of us i think have some sort
of grasp but we're we're mere
intellectuals we are
little people on the margin of things is
there any
big figure
any statesman
any
church leader i mean all the all the
things you used to look to i mean look
at archbishop welby
that absolutely vacuous windbag his
mouth stuffed with dreary business speak
i mean can there be a clearer
illustration of the the complete loss of
what was
one of the
intellectual scent intellectual and
the word let's utter it spiritual
centers than the performance that he put
up at the beginning of lockdown at the
the easter uh when he were he celebrated
the closure of churches by celebrating
holy communion in front of a kitchen
cabinet
can there be a more
appropriate metaphor
for
using that word that i shouldn't
for that
loss of meaning of seriousness
because that's what's happened isn't it
um maybe it's just that we're too
comfortable
that
that if you if you look at the
seriousness of culture in the soviet
union where
the the persistence of serious classical
music
the uh seriousness with which even the
communist state
took scholarship and learning
um
those terrible pressures were brought to
bear by totalitarianism
and our flaccid formless self-indulgent
consumerism i mean i'm as guilty with
anybody i'm a creature of the sixties
um
in many ways although i had to fight in
intellectually i had to fight um you
know through scholarships and all the
rest of it one had extraordinarily easy
life and it was a life of perpetual
opening opportunity
there was the whole hedonism of of the
developing gay lifestyle uh there was
the pleasure of increasing prosperity
we've had very very comfortable times in
other words there is a terrible whiff
isn't there
of the end of rome
um and the thing that's most striking
going to your point about the end of
rome is how invisible the emperors are
these these
you know the last emperor augustulous
romulus the little the littlest augustus
the littlest romulus these these
and hornorius who was without honor the
the disappearance of serious thinkers
the
the lack of proper generals and it's
awfully
reminiscent well this is what worries me
and i was going to ask you david because
you know we we we've addressed your
controversy
do you think part of the reason that the
caliber of thinkers of politicians of
our leaders our spiritual leaders
prevents people
who are big characters
who speak honestly sometimes wrongly
sometimes stupidly as you said they take
risks but they're prepared to make a
stand on principle which is always going
to alienate some people
they're prepared to speak their mind
which will always alienate some people
and they're prepared to take a risk
which doesn't always pay off as we know
but sometimes pays off hugely
we don't want those people anymore as a
society we punish those people yeah
it's particularly i was having a very
interesting discussion at the fire art
show last night with a couple of trainee
teachers and of course that is what has
exactly happened in teaching in some
ways for the best reasons and when i was
a school boy you had these monstrous
characters
completely extraordinary people clearly
half a significant number of them were
perverts um
and very often the best teachers again
things truths that we cannot speak
uh very often the people in my
experience of course because i'm much
older
so many of mine were returnees from the
war um they
they'd been shot up they'd had bad wars
they had good wars they could talk about
nothing else they couldn't mention it
but they were extraordinary people
and again teaching needs extraordinary
people you look at the you look at the
great writers of children's books every
one of them is semi-mad
and some of them are holy mad
um you know from lewis carroll downwards
and onwards um but they have this this
magical quality
that attracts and and holds attention
now of course we've replaced charisma
with celebrity
um which is an utterly empty thing
the famous for being famous
the point that you made just there is so
true when it comes to teaching because
when i was a teacher over 12 years
i saw
it changed it become a tick box exercise
it became did you meet this target this
target this target well it's actually
the people who were brilliant teachers
the mavericks the free thinkers the
people who could truly engage children
and make them wonder and make them want
to break out
or cross or angry
yes but involve them and involve them
and incite some kind of emotion in them
inspire them they slowly drifted away or
rapidly or rapidly forced out yes
because they didn't fit into a box and
that's what we want in our society we
want boxes we want a box you're a gay
man you're here you're trans you're here
you're straight you're here but life
doesn't work like that absolutely not
absolutely not but it is
we're in an age which is competent at
everything
and good at nothing
that that apart you know apart from
technological fiddles
you look at now in terms of say the
performing arts we are wonderful they've
never been more
competent performances
who is actually creating anything
look at the mountainous heap of rubbish
of modern art
it is absurd
it is simply absurd propelled of course
by people with too much money who treat
it simply as an investment opportunity
or something to decorate their
overpriced loft or bank atrium um so
we're in a we're in this never has the
word creativity been used more often
with less actually being created
and again there are all sorts of things
which are really very uncomfortable to
say
we generally speaking i think agree that
our politicians are and to put it as
mildly i know we're now supposed to be
nice about politicians following recent
events but they are a pretty uninspiring
lot i mean when
your greatest achievement um
is to
further the affairs of your constituency
well that's fine but
getting the streets cleaned really isn't
the most noble of human acts and there's
been
why's that happened well it is of course
the equivalent of what's happened to
teaching it's the creation of the
professional politician class in which
these people are paid and salaried
and
why has that happened because our old
governing class has died and been
deliberately wiped out now again there
was a huge amount wrong with the gentry
and the nobility but equally there were
these extr you look at churchill makes
his point brilliantly because of course
he was one of these people he points out
that we were better governed when our
elite was drawn from 600 families than
we are when it's drawn from 50 million
well talk about this
he's absent if you look at the caliber
of our 18th and 19th century politicians
if you look at the caliber of our 19th
century prime ministers you look at
figures like peel and gladstone and
israeli and they are
tigering in their sheer in their sheer
intellectual power let alone anything
else
not just really but but gladstone and
peel you know they are the absolute
stars of oxford they're highly competent
at maths they're brilliant classicists
and they they're sheer
as well as rhetorical power imagination
you look at what those two men do
and you compare it with any politician
of the later 20th century and they they
they shrivel to a pea
david there's another thing that you
bring up since we're talking about
controversial subjects and this is
something i think is very important i
told you i wouldn't
you did i didn't expect you to
to be faithful to that to be honest but
look
we talk about politicians and you you
mentioned the you allude to rather the
murder of sir david amos very recently
and one of the things i find absolutely
mind-boggling and perhaps you can help
me with this is
he was murdered as f to tall intents and
purposes as far as we know by an
islamist extremist he was radicalized
online
all by his father
well i i mean if i mean if you actually
look at the evidence of the kind of
things that his father was saying this
was clearly a family that was fully
islamic
fault you know well you come to the
point to the very point that i was
trying to make and i'm not aware of the
the situation with the father perhaps
you're better it's been widely reported
okay so
in response to that our politicians
reaction was to talk about online
anonymity deranged and
i
i think there's a very nuanced
conversation to be had about islam we've
had former al-qaeda
agents turned my sigs and formers on the
show i understand the the complexities
of that issue it's not as simple as some
people like to make it out to be but on
the other hand i i mean i just i think
it needs to be dealt with and addressed
and yet the response from our political
class is to ignore it and to talk about
something else i don't understand what's
happening there do you it is an elephant
in an arab head dress isn't it
in the room
i do understand it's too dangerous they
will not grasp it and we talk about no
this is the problem we don't talk about
any serious issues in politics we've
been through lockdown without actually
raising the fundamental question what is
the weight between saving so many lives
of primary people even older than i am
again shutting down an entire economy
and incurring debts on the same scale as
the second world war and killing people
as well and and of course by gross
mismanagement killing people in care
homes and but none of these debates
have been had at all
what is the cost of saving a life in
terms of the life of other people who
live how much do you spend i mean the
apparently the the average spend on uh
as it were saving a life in covit is
three times what the national health
will normally spend it's called a quarry
and a quality assessed year of life so
everywhere there's a refusal to debate
serious things it's just
it's too difficult it goes into that too
difficult box islamism is clearly a
fundamental issue but
it is part of a much bigger box of
issues which is
how do we live in a complex
uh society i don't use it well i have to
use the word multicultural in which
there are lots of different cultures
residing together it seems to me there
are two ways you can try to do it one is
what you were talking about with this
vision of the woke in which all cultures
have equal values and we are
fundamentally atomized into different
groups in which mysteriously although
they all hate each other
they will survive perfectly happily
alongside each other with of course no
police force
because the police are wicked so so all
of these rival mutually hating groups
will somehow in this wonderful nirvana
learn to live happily with each other
right that's the woke vision which is
why i'm sorry i said i didn't think it
was very serious now i've got a
different vision
which is and oddly enough this is what i
was talking about in the darron crime i
don't know whether you watched
the darren grimes video this is what i
was primarily talking about i was
talking about this thing called
biculturalism
and this is what i think the solution to
our society is and i learned about it
because i do occasionally listen to
people uh as well as talking at them and
i learned about it through my friendship
with somebody who was very very
different from me hugo grin on the moral
maze back in the late 1990s and hugo and
i were complete polar opposites you know
he was a liberal jew and i i was then a
sort of radical gay libertarian though
i've i've softened i've changed i've
become a radical gay tory
but but uh hugo and i had this very
sparring relationship in which there was
a wonderful exchange between us when you
were
very much alone here and david you're
not half as nasty as you seemed which my
response was hugo darling you're not
half as nice either
but hugo had the courage to take myself
and my late partner james into his home
for a passover and it was one of the
most memorable experiences i've ever had
i'd not understood judaism at all in
terms of the
in in a sense the synagogue is
dispensable that central rituals are
within the family
and within the home which of course is
why it survived 2 000 years of diaspora
and persecution but what was also
striking to me was this man who in
all intents and purposes was a very
important figure as british as they come
in british public life becoming somebody
completely different
a jew
invoking the rituals of two and a half
thousand years
but he was perfectly at home
in both of those worlds and if we look
at all our successful immigrant groups
that's what they do the you know the
hindus the sikhs whatever the chinese do
this with astonishing facility you look
at the members of the cabinet
of this astonishingly multicultural
cabinet again
i had a
fascinating insight a couple of years
ago when i was going around taking
various tours and we went to particular
stately home
and i'd arrived early and it turned out
to be a very good thing because there
there'd been a wedding party so there's
still lots of champagne lying around and
he
coughed it down and got talking with the
staff which is always an interesting
experience and it had been a marriage
between an english guy and and and the
hindu girl they had gone through because
they were clearly very comfortably off
in this grand stadium they'd gone
through no fewer than three ceremonies
you'd had a registry office wedding
you'd had a sort of christian wedding
and you'd had a hindu wedding and
it's a wonderful opportunity because you
had complete changes of clothes for all
of them um and you know the the the
bride wore white and the groom wore
tails and and then for the hindu wedding
they were they were swayed in silks and
saris and whatever and
this complete
cultural shift
but
but but one of those cultures has to
have primacy
it's the native one
it is it is the values of britain you
have to be
and it's the only way we can operate is
if this is where again my profound
disagreement with
blm with with burpal and whatever there
has to be that overarching culture
of
the liberal west
and
you can engage you can fit you can swap
you look again you know historically
um
i i happen to be a r r r r r r rather uh
uh uh passionate phylo semitic to to to
work you look at the achievement of
families like the rothschilds completely
british and yet
completely jewish
this double face
and this seems to me to be exactly what
we should be aiming for and why is it
that that is such a controversial point
because you you wouldn't be allowed if
you talked about that on news night i'd
give it about 23 seconds before
someone's tried to shout you down it's
quite extraordinary because again there
is the notion that the west is somehow
fundamentally wicked um and and of
course it is really that there are only
two groups that don't want
to fit in that pattern
and we both know what they are
and over where overwhelmingly it seems
to me our society without actually
articulating that or without having that
as a principle has seen what has
actually happened except of course that
the official line is a very different
one but if you look at what the
behavioral patterns have become they
have become in all successful immigrant
groups they've become this biculturalism
well look i've been talking about this
for a long time as a first generation
immigrant i talk about it in my book as
by the way i talk about the slavery
points that you made earlier that i
think uh the only way a multi-ethnic
society can work is if it rejects the
idea of multiculturalism and encourages
people to adopt the primary culture of
that society at first while also
retaining the valuable things about the
culture from from which they come and
there's no con the point is there is no
contradiction
unless of course you have again now
let's be frank and return to the the
problem with islam the great problem
with islam of course is that uh
jews islam i have a problem with
everybody don't do that
that makes life much simpler so
everybody can cancel me that's that's
really much better um the problem with
islam is of course that unlike
christianity it does not make a
distinction between church and state
that you know there is no equivalent to
that extraordinary moment in the bible
you know where's where um it's very very
very striking and again looking at many
modern christian attitudes um one of
jesus's disciples says to him you know
come on we shouldn't be paying taxes to
the romans should we um and jesus says
right hand me a coin they hand him a
coin he asks whose head is on this coin
of course it's caesar
and the wonderful remark render unto
caesar the things that he seizes and
unto god the things that are god
unfortunately islam
is a complete doctrine of life
in which politics and religion ideally
that's what the caliphate is about are
one and the same thing now that raises
absolutely fundamental problems and and
it raises again you know the campaign
for sharia law is is unthinkable
in a liberal democracy one simply cannot
have it you can you could allow it um as
for example with jewish law you can
allow it in certain forms of private
relations but even then you know because
of the very different attitudes to say a
divorce
you come up against a huge problem in
every state there has to be
a final i think set of values and a
final legal principle one cannot have
rival ones otherwise
this this is why there was a reformation
this is why there was the first brexit
against rome um
fundamentally there has to be that
bedrock
that that that generally accepted but
you see we stop teaching this
we
it is no longer fashionable or
respectable to do so our national
broadcaster actively campaigns against
it
isn't also the problem david of taboo
subjects we had ed west on the show a
few weeks ago and he made one of the
most pertinent points i've ever heard
where he said the problem with having
taboo subjects is it means you never
solve problems of course because faster
yeah
because you don't talk honestly about
what i was talking about
i've been making exactly the same point
we were talking again about how much
money do you spend on saving a life the
whole absurd distortion of the national
health in which you spend i think it's
if you look at how much money we spend
over a person's lifetime you spend
something like 70 percent of it in the
last year and half of their lives to
what purpose
to what purpose the absurdity of
somebody is suing the nhs now okay
we both agreed that the uh the way in
which care homes were handled and in a
sense the almost
jews were deliberate is wrong but the
reckless permitting the spread of covet
within them but to pretend as this
person is doing that the death of a 90
year old 90 year old man with
alzheimer's
from covet is a major tragedy please
please what this is
but this means this means that we've
lost any sense that sorry lives do have
different value well this is what i was
going to say do you think we've lost any
ability to have
our feelings have become so important
and of course if it's your parent it
doesn't matter if they're 190 and
they've got alzheimer's except that you
do slightly raise the question why
you've put them in the care
i'm sorry isn't it isn't a care home one
of these wonderful words it's orwellian
it means the opposite it's a careless
home it's an uncaring home it's i can't
be bothered to care home or i'm finding
it too difficult to care home just look
at what you can do
with the playing of that word that is
what it's really but dare we step what
we dare say it and it's high time we did
because this is the reason the nhs is
costing more and more and more again the
saving of lives of
brain-dead children
it's preposterous
because it's okay the parents want it
but if that child survives in that
condition it then becomes a vast cost
upon the state upon the rest of us you
see it's the problem that that as a
reaction to the horrors of eugenics and
nazism and whatever we have
it's feeling but it's false feeling it's
sentiment it's sentimentality we are
driven by sentimentality which is false
dramatic shallow displayed feeling
feelings not in the heart but feelings
worn on the sleeve
but we live in a society that
incentivizes
of course of course it does of course it
does um and and it is disastrous um and
we have politicians who are too frit
just to cite one who wasn't um uh
politicians who are too frit to tackle
it
and it's not only that but to me as well
it's the fact that we don't have
religion anymore in this country oh yes
we do um we oh yes we do god may have
died but you'll remember the wonderful
remark of gk chesterton that when people
no longer worship they god they don't
worship nothing they worship anything
and
everything that's going on now with woke
is a form of perverted religion i mean
the very notion of that this radical
equality is the magnificat you know and
he has exalted them of low degree he's
taken down the mighty from the seats
people big fat prosperous you know
overpaid white men like me and exalted
them of low degree you know professor
bhopal who happens to come from the
brahmin family and
you know in in her anxiety to point out
the moat in the eye of the west ignores
the beam of caste in india from which
she benefited from being high cast and
it just
there's a there's a there's an
extraordinary religiousness of all of
this the what i experienced was the
equivalent it did at least in the in the
days of the church you had a trial
before you condemned as a heretic i mean
this is this is just a witch lynching
you know you're hurt to the stake and
burned as quickly as possible um but
it's religious and this is why again why
we've ceased to be able to argue with
people and the whole problem with woke
is because its statements are so absurd
like i can become a woman merely because
i say so and you cannot
they cannot argue about them they become
articles of faith
when
this extraordinary case at the
university of
sussex at brighton or professor kathleen
stock and when she says you know i don't
actually believe that you do become a
woman the what do the trans say well
they actually is all the radical trials
what they say is we cannot be reasoned
out of existence
nobody is
nobody is challenging their existence
what we're challenging is their right to
force us to tell a lie which is to say
that a biological man can become a
biological woman you can't or to even
eliminate the notion of biology but this
is an act of religious faith this is
like saying you believe the bread and
the wine is the blood and the flesh and
blood of christ
you're asking us to believe in miracles
um
i mean if you think about it woke is the
miracle again the society right come on
i'm really running with the idea it's
the society that we have in which
wondrously uh palestinians and jews are
going to be completely happy
in this in this marvelous utopia it's
the lion lying down with the lamb i mean
just think about it all of all of those
religious ideas are now translated and
vulgarized into
the real world
but of course it's an absurdity because
the lion could lie down with the lamb
only at the second coming of christ what
these people are trying to do is to
bring about the
second coming here and now
america of course you see has had this
right through the 19th century there
were the great awakenings the great
surges because all very puritanical as
well clearly the woke believe they're a
new elect and titanic certain to go to
paradise and the rest of us are wicked
and corrupt and and fundamentally you
know
we should go to hell and before we do
our life should be made hell here on
earth for us but the the phrase that is
is marvelous is um i think i've coined
it but a friend of mine actually said
somebody got there before it we should
be talking about the great awakening
it's it's a manifestly religious
movement
i'm afraid
secularized religion like that is the
most dangerous form of human behavior it
has got none of the restraints of real
religion it's got none of the restraints
it's the seriousness of theology it is
the
literally the blood and guts of the
thing
driven by the meanest the most dangerous
and the most unsuppressed of emotions
you see a new romantic movement
um
it's it's in one sense
what are we really saying this is a vast
reaction to the technological world we
live in
the world of
because remember in many ways technology
to an ordinary person seems like a
miracle how about you i really do think
when i look at a mobile phone there's
something almost miraculous about i have
absolutely no comprehension of what is
going on inside this thing and it seems
to be able to do what once upon a time
took an entire
room full of secretaries assistance and
everything else so
but equally of course it's an object
it's a thing
um it's polished smooth profoundly
unhuman as so much of our society is and
i think what we're doing is as with the
18th century as with that
period of elegance formality brilliance
and whatever there's this violent
reaction the age of reason is followed
by the age of unreason of romanticism of
passion and byron and beethoven um of
wagner you know great lushing waves of
of passion sex emotion violence war
and
we're
seeing this in almost i think a parody
form
it um the
of course the woke don't know anything
or understand anything but they're like
an extreme form of russo you know who on
the one hand proclaims that he loves all
mankind and on the other hand puts his
own children in an orphanage
with the point of religion the point
that i was trying to make and that point
is incredibly valued that you just made
but one of the things religion does that
the work religion does not do is it
gives us comfort with the knowledge of
our own mortality
and to me on our own floor and our own
flaws
all of those things but particularly
mortality because we have we seem on the
surface to have solved everything in our
society apart from death we haven't seen
to solve that and you look at everything
that is happening now it's because we
can't accept we're going to die
we know that we're going to die there's
an end therefore i don't want to feel
discomfort therefore i don't want to be
upset therefore i don't want to have
confrontations because i've got a
limited amount of time here and i'm
going to be pleasure-seeking to the max
which is why i don't want to get married
it's why i don't want to have kids it's
all about me me me but the problem is
with our society if you just have purely
selfish individuals operating in that
manner you're never going to have social
cohesion of course not um i mean i think
you've confused two things
i think that that that the question of
refusing to accept death is utterly
fundamental the uh it means that that
there's a wonderful joke i mean you're
you're being the serious one i'll tell
the jokes
[Music]
there's a marvelous remark there's a
marvel destroyed but very softly
there's a marvelous remark about
americans who are determined to die in a
state of perfect health
and there is that refusal to accept that
we are mortal and we are frail and we
will die which is why this absurd
attempts at prolonging lives that
frankly are not worth prolonging this
refusal to accept that with the state of
modern medicine
some form of euthanasia if people want
it is the sensible way to handle all of
this again the absolute refusal to have
a serious serious and proper debate uh
on this subject the other one though i
think is is different i mean it is the
the
i'm not quite sure why you think that an
acceptance of death and
values other than pure solipsistic
selfishness and pure narcissism are
directly connected i don't think they
are i mean i think that it's possible to
have
perfectly sensible attitudes in these
areas but and i think it's it's
fundamentally the narcissism and the
solipsism
of our society um
but you see i think there's a reason for
this
none of this is accidental sorry this is
this is i'm not a determinist historian
but none of this is accidental
liberalism
from which i benefited we all have one
way or another obviously i as a gay man
benefited enormously from the
transformation of of of attitudes so in
one sense i'm biting a hand that fed me
and indulged me but liberalism has no
end
there is no reason for it to stop
so the liberalism of the 18th century
ended in the horrors of the terror of
the french revolution
the the reason of the 18th century
turned into a parody of itself with the
you know the goddess of reason as a
half-draped actress of the comedy
frances and on that on the desecrated
high altar of notre dame this this awful
parody in the same way the liberalism of
the 60s ends in woke
what if you look at what's happened
within gay lib i was right at the
beginning of it you know i was i was
dare i said even occasionally going on a
demonstration part me at a time when the
ian mckellens of this world was were
carefully parading their heterosexuality
because it might have damaged their
stage careers um but
if you look at that progression if you
look at you know gay freedom lesbian
freedom well then in one sense you can
see then okay bisexual freedom well then
the next stage is trans freedom um
but trans freedom
if it then becomes
we've got to believe you
when we were talking about
liberalization for gays lesbians
bisexuals we're saying
please can we be recognized for what we
are
and not penalize for it
trans is something completely different
it's saying please can we be recognized
for what we want to be
for what we imagine we are and by the
way if you don't believe in me i'm going
to destroy your career now that seems to
me that's the equivalent of the terror
of the french revolution it's when
freedom turns against itself and
consumes itself it's the phrase
revolutions always end by consuming
themselves they're self-consuming
processes i'm afraid the same is true of
liberalism and it's
strikingly it's israeli i think the
greatest practical political thinker of
the 19th century in the same way that
churchill was the greatest practical
political thinker of the 20th century
the israeli recognizes that liberalism
is the enemy
and the the this deracinated liberalism
uh this thing that dissolves everything
the prime example in our recent history
is the utter catastrophe of the blair
government everything that it touched
turned to pitch
be it
scotland be it the supreme court be it
whatever northern
ireland will northern carson no pudding
kosovo kosovo of course is simply an eu
colony
so it's an eu i mean what's happened in
the balkans is an absurdity
um uh the i do think in one in one sense
i know this sounds appalling the
historically the way disputes like um
like like the balkans are settled i'm
afraid it's by war that is how the
frontiers of you know this that's how
the frontiers of eastern europe were
settled at the end of the first world
war with huge movements of population
painful and horrible but that's how the
problem is really solved not creating
this enforced patchwork of unsustainable
stateless northern ireland for heaven's
sake
better i suppose than the terror but
pretending that the terrorists won
which is what i'm afraid the settlement
is based upon and with the imminent
prospect of the shinton government in
ireland
i suspect it will turn out to have been
just a bad a bad an idea there right but
we've opened enough cats at work for one
day david before we wrap up let me ask
you about one other subject which you've
you've referred to i've got one last
question as well but you don't i'll ask
my final question
uh i wanted to talk a little bit about
covid
uh not not not the modern situation and
what happened here and who said this and
whatever but
a historical perspective
i based on what i know and you know my
historical knowledge is obviously
limited
human beings have not dealt with
pandemics in this way before never
but human beings have dealt with many
pandemics before
so what do what what do we need to know
about periods of this kind in in human
history and what are we likely to have
to watch out for and expect with this
i think in a sense the way we dealt with
covid
was a direct reflection of everything
we've been talking about now
that we thought in a sense that um it
was
the notion that quite a lot of people
would die with something so monstrous
that we decided to shut down society
now no
this is the first time that a plague
it's a very very minor plague by the way
in comparison with the great plagues of
the uh say the um
the 14th and 15th century now the the
great the the black death eliminates
probably two-thirds of
this cumulative effect between half and
two-thirds of the population that's real
um this was a relatively minor blip but
for the first time we decided to inflict
more damage on ourselves in trying to
control the plague than the plague would
have done
if it had been given as it were
the the vex question of herd immunity
now you could argue this is because
we've developed proper attitudes to the
sacredness of life and the sanctity of
life that we no longer take the
indifference uh the relatively
indifferent view i mean our ancestors
had to take a relatively indifferent
view which is not to say that things
like quarantine and all the rest of it
were not very frequently applied i think
the problem is we also had a false model
we got a chinese virus and we decided to
have a chinese solution i mean the
lockdown is totally antithetical this is
the point jonathan assumption has been
making repeatedly it is absolutely
antithetical to british values to
western liberal values and it is a
testimony to the fundamental collapse of
those values that it's been allowed to
happen david let me interrupt you there
because you're making such a good point
and i want to just interject this
because i think this is so important and
you've allowed me to see something i've
been rummaging around in my head for a
while
i think what you're really saying
correct me if i'm wrong
is that we've forgotten that freedom
comes with cost absolutely
freedom has a price
freedom has a price in exactly the same
way that trying to that trying to
prevent death has a price and because
we've got into the habit of not having
serious conversations we've not debated
the balance between those two we've also
been sold completely bad science
the whole science of lockdown professor
lockdown neil ferguson is a fraud let's
just use this word this this absolute
word he
got
he used the same mathematical models for
bse he used the same mathematical models
for foot and mouth disease and he was
out by factors of scores
huge huge why this man is allowed to to
hold forth is beyond me it's it's bad
it's bad applied maths it's not medical
science but there is a science and the
science is that of vaccination now this
will surprise you i am absolutely in
favor of compulsory vaccination uh if
you actually look at one of the the
great reasons that we've eliminated
infectious illness it is vaccination
again the great british discovery uh
janna's discovery of vaccination of cow
pox which eliminated smallpox and
effectively it is compulsory and in the
same way
as a child i desperately liked the fact
that there wasn't a salt vaccine for
podio i because i never do things by
hearts i not only had club feet i caught
polio
and
from that point onwards every child was
vaccinated against polio you weren't
asked you're in a queue and you had
little needles pushed in your arm and
we've eliminated illness after illness
we also used to have because of the
omnipresence of infectious illness we
actually had we had isolation hospitals
we had fundamental powers of medical
offices of health all of which we threw
away in the 1960s so there is a way of
dealing with this and it is vaccination
and there's no libertarian argument
against it what about bodily autonomy
problem bodily autonomy
well you the state has no right to
inject something into my body without my
concern
i'm sorry and you're a member of a
society in which if you go around
unvaccinated you're likely to infect
others well the evidence isn't very
strong on that day um
the idea that vaccination prevents
infection is very very very limited
what is very limited well it certainly
limits the consequences of it no no
right
so the vaccine protects you against
serious illness and it protects you
against going to hospital and protects
you against dying it does not have any
strong evidence to suggest that it
prevents me from catching it from you
because you're vaccinated or no that's
right
that's not that's not the issue it
limits the consequences of infectious
disease this is why this is why small
sorry if you were right and i was wrong
we still have smallpox um that that it
is precisely the universality of
vaccination against smallpox that
effectively eradicated it because there
was nobody left getting smallpox and
therefore nobody caught it even though
not everybody is vaccinated against it
now
and and sorry this really does seem to
me to be an app there is a science
there's a real medical science but one
of the problems is again
we've had
public debate is so slovenly and the
government used the science as a get out
card as a as as an ass covering card and
of course the scientists the scientists
some of whom weren't i had no idea we
had so many so many serious experts in
in epidemiology so i had no idea the
country was crawling with people who
understood everything about virology
amazingly every tenth rate academic and
every eighth grade university popped up
on stage
and the behavior of sage everybody going
shocking you're there to give advice to
a government the moment you've given the
advice what you do you then all jostle
and struggle to get on question time or
to appear on the news and to become
little stars now that's not that really
isn't
what you should be doing so i'm afraid
the whole thing has shown
our reaction to covid has shown i think
the extent to which we are in a fully
decadent society
it's shown an absolute refusal to ask
big questions it has shown
vanity uh the vanity of the scientist um
me me me
it has shown the
absolute incomprehension of how medicine
actually works i think he's appointing
me
no i i don't know i'm sorry i don't
accept this okay that's fine we'll then
then right let us give an example to
everybody and we'll agree to disagree um
um
but but and the complete ignoring of
history as to how these things have been
dealt with before um
on the other hand it's shown something
else which is the wonders of private
enterprise
that is to say the discovery of the
vaccine
the extraordinary rapid development of
its manufacture and isn't it very
striking
everywhere you look
the status performed badly do you
remember testing compare the testing
regime you done through the nhs and and
and through public health england and
compare on the other hand the private
enterprise development of the vaccine
look again do you remember right at the
beginning people were going on about oh
we need rationing we need a national
food service and how quickly the
supermarket sorted it out have you
noticed how quickly even the petrol
shortage has gone away imagine if we'd
had a state supply of of petroleum uh
and state-run uh um petrol stations and
state-run we'd solved the climate crisis
it wouldn't be a single moving car on
lorry in britain but isn't it i'm being
really serious um
and at the same time we are constantly
piling more and more onto the state as
the state becomes more and more
incompetent as its reach extends
well i grew up in the soviet union
but unfortunately so
the people in britain didn't boris
johnson did not grow up in the soviet
union and we're now seeing this
extraordinary paradox of a of a
so-called conservative government that
seems to think that the state is the
solution when but it's faced with the
manifesting competence of everything
from dvlc to uh to to the inland revenue
to to
the one thing that still preserves some
sort of sense is the treasury but that's
about all
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
there was a moment earlier on in the
interview which i think when we touched
on art because to me
art is very very important art reflects
the culture that reflects the society
and we would i think it does so
brilliantly yeah look look at look at
the turner prize yeah look
look at jeff coons yeah look you know
this is the art of decadence and
absurdity look look at look at the
whatever it is it's an ice cream cone
with a cherry on it shoved on a pedestal
into the square yes absolutely but what
it shows is that we have a dearth of
ideas there's no fresh ideas there's no
new way of looking
the hope the whole thing is is that
funny notion of marcel duchamp uh back
in
at the end of the first world war that
anything is a nod you know what it's
exactly the same as trans what dushan
said was a urinal is a work of art
because i say it is
it's exactly you see what i mean it's
exactly the same phenomenon it's the
phenomenon of words the whole business
of conceptual art it's the phenomenon of
the word actually given priority over
the craft the act of painting carving or
whatever it is and of course the
solipsism and the you know just the
focus in on the self of because i say it
is it is or the fundamental it's a
miracle um because i say it's a work of
art
the one turner exhibit was turning on
and off a light switch
quite seriously and and this thing it
receives enormous amounts of public
money
the arts council is fixated on this
rubbish
and is rubbish and it's his complete
emperor's new clothes
and but what is most astonishing about
it francis you put your finger on it
it's old emperor if you're if you can
have an old presumably it means you've
got a withered willy you know kind of
old emperor's new clothes because these
are ideas that have been knocking around
since the beginning of the 20th century
there are 100 years old it's 100 years
of of waving two fingers and calling it
art
david i said it i had the last question
but i've got one more
and it's personal to you because i want
to finish where we started the interview
which is
what do we do with people like you in
society people who are talented and
brilliant but also take risks and make
mistakes and sometimes say things that
are insensitive and some people find it
always insensitive yeah
what do i mean we talked about the
reaction to your situation which i agree
with you was excessive
but what should we do when someone says
the wrong thing i think we've forgotten
the answer to that question i don't know
what the answer is what should we do
when people say something offensive well
the sensible thing is usually to say a
silly old fool ignore him um if
which is what one tended to do um
the
the other is perhaps to listen
because of course you see
again i've been comparing myself to
churchill
with typical modesty i will now compare
myself to the prophet people like me are
the equivalent of the prophets of the
old testament we are the nace or the
cassandras and again you remember what
happened to cassandra she was ignored
she told the truth that she was ignored
which seems to me to be pretty a pretty
accurate uh description and
what should we do
well i suppose
you should really listen to things that
challenge you
but it's very difficult to
persuade people to do that you have to
sugar pill so it needs people who are
more tactful than i am um and probably
subtler
and
more insinuating more snake-like
[Music]
to carry these things through but every
to now to be completely serious
societies depend on dissent you know
this from the soviet union societies
that try to suppress dissent die
it is very simple i come from i'm
talking about it i come from long
generations of religious dissenters of
people who said no i do not accept what
is publicly enforced belief i think it
is wrong and if you actually look at in
every society it is these marginal
groups that are high creatives as i said
we
never is the word creativity been so
misused if you look at the record of
quakers in england if you look at the
record of jews if you in in russia if
you look at the record of old believers
where every inf you know the
immigrants in britain
like like the the religious refugees
from france the huguenot or whatever the
louis xiv destroyed france when he drove
out the huguenot they were the most
intelligent the most creative the most
brilliant craftsmen the reason that in
england you suddenly get this
extraordinary development of everything
from furniture to silversmith work in
the in the early 18th century is because
louis xiv whom churchill uses as the
model for hitler and drove out the drove
out the huguenot the the protestants
from france they were the greatest of
you look at their names they're echoing
through the manufacture of silver in
18th century england they're french
french french they're huguenots but
they're marginal they're dissenters and
a society that loses sight of this
is finished we used to have the
reputation of english eccentricity
going
and again it's one of the things i know
this sounds a real paradox it's one of
the things i worry about uh insofar as i
don't really worry about it but if i if
if i put on a program like this and ask
to find something to worry about
it is about gay about gay life we used
to be dissenters now of course you know
it's practically compulsory as one of
one of one of the more discontented
members of my department at lse was
remarked um
and and
as it mainstreams and you know what
happens now generally i think when you
come out and one of my younger gay
friends said you know it was absolutely
terrible what happened just awful i said
what was it he said well my mother said
you know
what's your boyfriend called am i going
to like him
when's the wedding what am i for
heaven's sake here you are making this
heart-rending confession and it's just
treated as an excuse for a new pair of
shoes and
if you again if you look at the gay
world that produced people like oscar
wilde that's not going to happen again
stephen fry is a very bargained basement
version of oscar wilde
i suppose i'm now arguing for
persecution
but the point again about the soviet
union
dissent is very important david yeah
yeah and
it's
an unhealthy society that cannot process
dissent it's like a human being a human
being that can't handle disagreement is
an unhealthy human being and society is
the same which is why it's been a
pleasure to have you back
thank you we're going to have some
questions for our local supporters but
the last question we always ask is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be having fun
and we've made it all so serious i mean
one of the things that sustained me in
all of this is
i've been i've been attacking simple
pleasure seeking but one needs to enjoy
life
i love doing this i love debate i love
the pleasures of food and drink
in the days when they're more readily
available i love the pleasures of sex
but it's not that destructive hedonism
that just complete repetition it is the
enjoyment the savoring it i you know
good food drink and decent furniture
things that are beautiful
the the we were talking about art
all of that
these are the things that again using
very unfashionable language elevators
take us beyond ourselves but can also
unite us with other people
what a wonderful note to end on and
david you've also got a youtube channel
that you're starting why don't you tell
the viewers about that and the listeners
uh well it's going to be called very
surprisingly david starkey talks
when is he ever my mother had a
wonderful line all that your tongue will
be the ruiner view she said and she was
of course absolutely right and
absolutely wrong it's been the making
and the unmaking i'm going to be talking
primally about history i'm going to try
and do it very free form it's not going
to be like a television documentary
those days are a bit past i think it's
going to be the equivalent of
i've always enjoyed lecturing
and what we mentioned beforehand and i
think i should say this safely now i've
always regarded public speaking as the
best form of oral sex so what
what this is going to be it's the
equivalent of me doing an ex-temporary
lecture which is the thing i most
enjoyed when i was an academic and i'm
going to be doing an in on a huge range
of topics obviously i'll be covering the
tutors obviously i'll be covering the
monarchy but i've just done one that i
think is really great on a statue the
statue of somebody was in the slave
trade a man called william beckford one
of the biggest objects in the guildhall
in london but he was also a leading
campaigner for radical politics and
liberty and the extension of the
franchise
slave owner
radical libertarian and
that's of course the paradox at the
heart of the american revolution
so it what i will try and do i will try
and give people that sense of the
engagement with the mind i mean it was
what i i loved aspects of teaching
in the years when i was a university
teacher and in which
but again it needs what you were talking
about it needs the ability to talk
without limits
to talk
to criticize but not to criticize to
destroy but to criticize to develop and
to encourage and but above all to open
the mind history is wonderful because by
definition you have to engage with
different values see this is the great
problem the refusal to accept there can
be any other values and the values of
the moment and sir thomas moore had
values that were pretty much the
opposite of ours that doesn't mean that
he was a bad man he was a very great man
but he just happened to have different
values it's a form of mental tourism
that genuinely broadens the mind and so
i'll be trying to
a bit and i think talking
is
we all know about reading and reading is
utterly fundamentally important but i
think talking that
we talk about the author's voice with
the book but talking talking the thing
that's now offered with things like
youtube actually enables you to have
the reality of that conversation
of two minds
i'm sure i will not get it right to
begin with there'll be a period of
experiment
i'm hoping people will bear with me uh
and enjoy it and criticize me which i'm
very happy um but also that we can all
learn a little bit from each other but
david i'm very much looking forward to
and as someone who runs a youtube
channel i assure you there will be
plenty of criticism don't you worry
about that
david uh david starkey talks i'm really
looking forward to it thank you so much
for coming back and thank you all for
watching and listening at home we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show they
always go out at 7pm uk
2 p.m eastern standard or if you like
your trigonometry on the go always
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below